[Musique]
pour être élu il faut une énergie folle
il faut une confiance folle il faut
foncer droit devant il faut partir à
fond et
accélérer tout président au moment où
accède à cette responsabilité est
enfermé
faut du calme faut beaucoup de
sangfroid beaucoup d'ter pour éviter de
se prendre à
mur mais il y a une très grande
contradiction dans la société française
nous voulons un président qui puisse
être au sommet je vous a compris décider
de de notre destin commun et nous le
voulons accessible comment réussir cette
cette conjugaison c'est la 5è
République président fait partie de la
la famille des gens qui vous aime ou qui
vous aime pas et donc il faut être prêt
à payer le
[Musique]
prix mes chers
compatriotes aujourd'hui la France a
attaqué en son cœur c'est la République
toute entière qui est
mobilisée pour faire face à ce drame la
communauté de tous les Français doit se
resserrer et non se diviser
j'ordonne que tous les moyens je dis
tous les moyens soit employé partout
pour châtier
impitoyablement les assassins et que
personne ne croit que les obstacles me
feront changer de route ils ne passeront
pas la question du terrorisme c'est
est-ce que toutes les mesures ont été
prises est-ce qu'on a suffisamment
anticipé est-ce qu'on
a été suffisamment ferme est-ce que
notre diplomatie correspond à ce qu'il
faut faire est-ce que nous avons eu les
contacts suffisants avec X avec Y et en
même temps il faut laisser la place pour
ce que j'appelais le toucher la
sensibilité le l'émotion le terrain
sinon vous êtes un ordinateur qui se
trompe en
1958 la 4e République s'effondre
paralysé par l'instabilité
gouvernementale rappelé au pouvoir le
général de Gaulle doit d'abord rétablir
l'ordre et l'autorité en
Algérie il a été porté au pouvoir voir
par l'Algérie
française c'est pas la peine de de
prendre des nuances je vous ai
compris ce jour-là il est apparu en
effet comme l'homme de la nation et puis
il s'en est détaché en étant d'une
impassibilité parfois même d'une cruauté
qui a été ressentie comme terrible par
une partie de ceux qu'il avait porté au
pouvoir de Gaou va ensuite s'employer à
négocier la paix avec le FLN qui a lancé
une insurrection
armée pour s'opposer à la politique
Gauliste en haut gradé le général Salan
choisit la rébellion il crée un
mouvement terroriste l'OAS qui au nom de
l'Algérie française va multiplier les
attentats la liste des explosion
s'allongue l'OAS comprendra-t-elle la
criminelle folie de ces méthodes
aveugles qui heurent toutes les
consciences ça a été une affaire très
violente les événements d'Algérie très
violente en Algérie est très violente en
métropole quand vous êtes un enfant
c'est c'est quelque chose de
d'extrêmement violent
l'OAS
pardon ce que j'ai vécu moi et d'autres
avec des milliers de
morts près de 3000 morts en Algérie 70
morts et 400 blessés en métropole c'est
le terrible bilan des terroristes de
l'OAS
j'ordonne que tous les moyens je dis
tous les moyens soit employé
partout pour barrer la route à ses homm
là le général a
réagi par les moyens de
l'État et par des moyens autres aussi
c'est-à-dire de ces
fidèles les services secrets leur
prolongement diverses et
varié parce qu'il fallait faire face le
8 avril la métropole approuve plus de
90% la politique algérienne du général
de GA le 20 général sal est arrêté
transféré à la santé dans 23
jours pour la France le problème
algérien sera résolu l'Algérie disposera
d'attentat du
petitam PRES an après l'attentat qu'ait
visé sur la route de Ch le général de
Gaulle a une nouvelle fois servi de
cible à ses adversaires
déterminés c'est miracles peut-on dire
que ni le président ni madame de gale n
été atteint par les
balles qui est important dansatt c'est
toutes les conséquences qui va y avoir
après et notamment
institutionnell face à toutes les
entreprises
faeuse de quelque côté qu'elle
vienne le président de la République
sera d'oravante élu au suffrage
universel
[Musique]
pour de Gaulle l'élection au suffrage
universel est le meilleur moyen de
renforcer la légitimité du président et
d'assurer la continuité de
l'État 3 ans plus tard il devient le
premier président élu directement par
les
Français les vraies logiques de la
puissance de l'autorité du leadership
c'est d'avoir confiance en soi-même
d'avoir confiance dans ce qu'on est
confiance dans nos valeurs confiance
dans notre unité nationale c'est la
mobilisation de notre énergie et essayer
de donner de la force à ceux qui vous
suivent cette union nationale sera
malmenée 15 ans plus tard pendant la
présidence de Valérie Giscard desestin
au moment du terrible attentat devant la
synagogue de la rue copernque des
nouvelles de l'attentat qui s'est
produit il y a un peu plus d'une
demi-heure r rue Copernic dans le 16e
arrondissement dans une synagogue bilan
trois morts deux hommes et une femme
pour la première fois depuis la fin de
la deuxème guerre mondiale on a tenté
d'assassiner des Français parce qu'ils
sont
juifs cet attentat antisémite qui fera
finalement quatre morts et 50 blessés
provoque une profonde émotion la
réaction de Raymond bar Premier ministre
de giscar choque les Français et
déclenche la polémique je rentre de Lyon
plein
d'indignation à l'égard de cette
attentat auieu qui voulait
frapper les israélit qui se rendaient à
la synagogue et qui a frappé des
Français
innocent la classe politique condamne
immédiatement l'antisémitisme et le
terrorisme le lendemain une
manifestation rassemble une foule
considérable on y retrouve François
mideran et Simon
VE au caractère criminel quelques jours
plus tard le chef de l'État critiqué
pour son absence sur place après
l'attentat s'adresse au français la
communauté de tous les Français doit se
resserrer et non se diviser ou se
séparer à peine élu françan est
confronté au terrorisme du Moyen Orient
avec des attentats en série qui vont
marquer les années
la déflagration a déchicteté le flanc
gauche du
TGV deux passagers ont été tués sur le
coup quatre autres personnes ont été
gravement blessées elles ont été
déféestrées le commando a pris la fuite
à pied tout en continuant à tirer sur
toutes les personnes se présentant
devant lui des scènes de panique se sont
produit les passants nombreux à cette
heure cherchant désespérément refuge
lorsque le restaurant Goldenberg rue des
rosers à Paris est frappé par une
explosion FOM est le premier président à
se déplacer sur les lieux d'un attentat
puis il assiste à l'office
religieux les obstacles sont nombreux
vous le savez tous les Français le
savent mais que personne ne croit que
les obstacles me feront changer de route
miter est quand même tendant sur les
questions de politique étrangère et de
défense encore plus à faire les choses
tout seul et à ne pas impliquer
suffisamment son gouvernement disait
politique de défense politique
internationale donc terrorisme euh c'est
moi euh le président qui m'en occupe et
moi dans mes fonctions je m'en suis très
très peu occupé ce matin à l'aube deux
attentats double attentat contre le
contingent français et américain à
Beyrouth au moins 70 marines tuées trois
morts 56 disparus du côté français
président mitteran immédiatement a
décidé d'aller sur place donc c'est des
gens qui étaient morts pour la France et
c'était horriblement émouvant enfin le
le fait d'aller là sur l'emplacement de
l'immeuble dracard et donc il a eu des
des moments de recueillement il y a eu
très peu de paroles en fait et tout de
suite après s'est posé la question du du
départ parce que pour redécoller il
fallait précisément de façon encore plus
dangereuse passer au-dessus de tous les
quartiers sud donc je pense vraiment
qu'il y avait un vrai risque que l'avion
soit touché par un missile oui
oui bon on m'annonce donc maintenant que
le président mitteran vient de faire son
entrée à l'Élysée nous l'écoutons sur
place j'ai pu éprouver le courage et le
sang-froid de
tous j'ai apprécié les dispositions pris
ou à
prendre pour une meilleure sécurité et
pour répondre aux
agressions ça correspond pas du tout à
la personnalité de François mitteron
ni à son sangfroid ni sa maîtrise de
lui-même il est pas du tout de la
culture où il faut vivre en exhibant ses
émotions toute la journée hein c'est un
autre monde je vous rappelle qu'un
nouvel attentat a été commis en fin
d'après-midi à 17h25 rue de reen à Paris
dans le grand magasin
Tati cet attentat fait 7 morts et 55
blessés c'est le plus grave des
attentats commis en quelques semaine
dans la capitale par les terroristes
pro-iraniens la c'est en cohabitation
François mitteran et Jacques Chirac
parlent d'une même voix priorité absolue
à l'Union nationale le Premier ministre
Jacques Chirac a immédiatement convoqué
le conseil de
sécurité 7 ans plus tard après la large
victoire de l'opposition législative
François mitteran nomme Édouard Baladur
Premier ministre c'est le début de la
deuxèe
cohabitation voilà s'il vous plaît
Nathalie vous pouvez vous retirer du
champ merci puisqu'on voit arriver
Édouard Baladur accompagné par le
secrétaire général de l'Élysée Hubert
Vedrine Édouard Baladur nouveau Premier
ministre issu de la nouvelle majorité
écoutons-le on m'avait téléphoné la
veille de Noël pour me dire que il y
avait un avion Airbus français pris en
otage par des terroristes sur l'aéroport
d'Alger la prise d'otage à l'aéroport
d'Alger serait en train de tourner au
drame selon des témoins des coups de feu
auraient été entendus dans l'après-midi
trois personnes auraient été tué par le
commando on est dans une ambiance où le
terrorisme monte terrorisme islamique en
général même s'il y a eu un très très
long dénis de la part des des opinions
des dirigeants en Occident et notamment
en Europe et notamment en France c'est
le premier épisode spectaculaire il y
avait plus de 200 français et on m'a
appelé pour m'expliquer que le
gouvernement algérien refusait de faire
intervenir les forces de l'ordre contre
les terroristes et que la situation se
tendait les pirates de l'air
apptiendrait au GIA le Groupe islamique
armé le plus radical des mouvements
algériens alors vers 2h de l'après-midi
j'ai réuni les ministres compétent je
reçois un coup de téléphone du directeur
du cabinet de Premier ministre Nicolas
Bir qui me dit le Premier ministre veut
que tu arrives tout de suite Charles
pascoy voulait qu'on laisse l'avion à
Alger le ministère de l'intérieur était
pas très désireux que l'avion rentre
parce que ce cétait lui à régler le
problème à ce moment-là et on est venu
me dire mais vous savez si vous le
faites rentrz en France vous prenez un
grand risque politique parce que ce sera
à vous de régler le problème et comme il
est question que vous soyez candidat à
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
risque qu'il faudrait mieux que vous ne
preniez pas et j'ai répondu que ce
serait une lâcheé un signe cet avion je
demandais qu'il rentre il était exclu
qu'on le laisse aller à
Paris et on avait décidé de le faire
atterrir à Marignane en faisant croire
qu'il y avait un plein d'essens à faire
et que c'était très compliqué pourquoi
on l'a arrêté à Marseille parce que nous
avions
intercepté des écoutes dans lequel il
était évoqué l'idée d'un crash suicide
sur Paris et le bruit s'était répandu
qu'il ferait voyez comme les choses se
perpétuent euh qui ferait un attentat et
qui se jetterait sur la Tour
[Musique]
Effel moi j'ai pris deux décisions dans
cette affaire et j'ai pris seul toutes
les deux un j'ai fait rentrer l'avion en
France et deux j'ai fait décider
l'assaut au bout de de 12h on a déjeuné
dans son bureau Nicolas Bazir le Premier
ministre et moi en regardant
lesess retour immédiatement à Marignan
et en fin d'après-midi entre cette
période entre chien et loup là tout d'un
coup des coups de feu
ont été
entendus et nous avons
pensé qu'ils étaient en train d'abatt
des
otages c'est à ce moment-là que le
premier ministre a donné l'ordre de
l'assaut au gignn et il y a cette image
extraordinaire de l'échelle de coupée
qui a approche et du Gar GGN qui qui est
déséquilibré et ça a été formidable
parce que ces quatre agents du GIGN
commandés par le colonel
Fabier en de temp trois mouvements ils
ont abattu les quatre terroristes et ils
ont sauvé 200 français c'est un miracle
qui est pas une mort chez Tage c'est un
miracle et on voit cette cette image
extraordinaire du copilote qui descend
par la fenêtre qui saute et qui se casse
la
jamb je vois Édouard baladiur avec
beaucoup de calme ça m'a beaucoup appris
sur la maîtrise des choses c'était une
décision quand même assez risquée ça
aurait pu être un bain de sang
c'est à moi qu'on l'aurait reproché à
juste titre d'ailleurs et donc il y
avait pas beaucoup de concurrence pour
venir me donner des conseils et prendre
ma place vous parlez du président de la
République
euh j'en pas entendu parler il se trouve
que le présidant était à Venise donc je
l'appelle il me dit naturellement vous y
allez et il me dit vous me tener au
courant donc ma mission était simple de
l'informer régulièrement des discussions
l'évaluation de la situation
l'évaluation des risques et des
décisions ce que j'ai fait pendant toute
la durée de la crise secrétaire général
d'élysée était informé par mes
collaborateurs rien n était
caché et il avait tout le loisir de me
téléphoner s'il souhaitait me téléphoner
et à aucun moment il m'a demandé à
disons aller contre ce qui était tranché
par le Premier ministre qui était très
clair très rapide il écoutait les uns et
les autres et il avait un prise de
décision ilit pas hésitant dans la prise
de décision chaque fois que je l'ai
informé mon milit on été d'accord s'il y
avait eu un vrai désaccord au sommet à
la fin des fins je pense que c'est la
position du président qui l'aurait
emporté c'est le numéro 1 de l'exécutif
qui a le dernier
mot le terrorisme l'ai connu en arrivant
au ministère de l'Intérieur quelques
jours après arrivé ministère de
l'intérieur on m'apprend qu'il y a une
explosion dans le métro
[Musique]
Saint-Michel B la première réaction
quand même c'est
onivin lui comme moi donc on n'hésite
pas ma première réaction est évidemment
être bouleversé devant ce que je viens
de voir en l'état actuel des choses
quatre victimes qui sont décédées et une
quarantaine une cinquantaine de blessés
dans un état plus ou moins grave je vais
vous faire un aveu moi j'avais jamais vu
de cadavre
sanglant jamais j'ai pas fait la guerre
hein je suis né en 45 j'ai pas été en
Algérie j'ai pas été non plus avant
l'ochine naturellement donc je n'avais
jamais vu une scène de de guerre donc
c'est un choc une émotion forte il faut
tenir aujourd'hui encore euh il m'arrive
de de penser de
voir ce que j'ai vu au métroort royale
euh notamment de ses de ses
corps percé de clous puisqu'il mettait
sur les bombes des clous c'est quelque
chose qui jusqu'au dernier jour
entra et là je dois dire que la présence
de Chirac m'a aidé parce que lui il fait
preuve dans ce genre de circonstan d'un
d'un sang frroid et pour un chef du
gouvernement un peu inexper expérimenté
comme je l'étais c'est c'est un point
d'ancrage très très fortvez Chirac est
un personnage complexe donne souvent
l'impression d'une sorte d'impassibilité
alors qu'il est beaucoup plus torturé
qu'on ne le pense mais là dans ce genre
de situation il tient il s'adresse à la
nation moi j'actionne les services le
Premier ministre qui s'est rendu
immédiatement sur
place m'a rendu
compte et m'a indiqué sa
décision de remettre immédiatement en
vigueur le plan Vigi pirate est-ce qu'on
met en place
pour que les service de
renseignement se déploie avec plus
d'efficacité et cetera donc on pense
tout de suite à ce qu'on peut faire pour
que ça ne recommence pas bonjour 17
blessés dont trois grièvements ce matin
10 personnes sont encore hospitalisées
Paris 23 jours après l'explosion de
Saint-Michel qui avait fait se morts
même heure même cible la même technique
il est 17h05 hier place Charles de
Gaulle une bombe explose vous avez une
rage de découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
osé faire ça peu importe en vertu de
quelle idéologie vous voulez les arrêter
et vous êtes nuit et jour nuit et jours
vous êtes obsédé par ça et qu'une somme
de 1 million de francs serait offert à
toute personne qui nous fournirait des
éléments
permettant
l'identification et l'arrestation du ou
des coupables le ministre d'intérieur
est confronté à la les médias qui à
longueur de journée vous explique qui
qui comment et où la bombe est arrivée
par qui a été posée et cetera je ne peux
pas moi je peux pas vous dire qui alors
on va mener des investigations et j'ai
pu me maintenir grâce au soutien
du président de la République Jacques
Chirac qui tous les matins m'appelait
dans fait t'en fais pas tu vas encore
être critiqué poursuit et je l'informais
pratiquement tous les jours de
l'évolution de l'enquête les policiers
ont réussi à identifier les empreintes
relevées sur la bombonne du TGV depuis
ils suivent la piste de Ralet Kelkal à
l'époque on a fait une nouveauté les
affiches avec le portrait du suspect on
a affiché partout il y a une radio qui
offrait je sais pas combien de de francs
à toute personne qui donnerait une
information
importante
et je me souviens qu'on
apprend par la radio périphérique en
question que la personne qu'on recherche
se trouve dans le bois de Malval c'est
bien quand on arrive et ben on arrive
pas seul il y a déjà toutes les
télévisions toutes les radios pendant 2
jours traqués par les gendarmes ed
Kelkal n'avait donc pas réussi à passer
à travers les mailles du filet sur lui
les enquêteurs ont trouvé un couteau une
boussole et des cartes d'étatmajor qui
lui ont permis de parcourir les quelques
kilomètres entre le lieu de la fusillade
de mercredi et la Maison Blanche où il
sera tué et c'est ça aussi la difficulté
de la lutte contre dans ce système
médiatique aujourd'hui de la lutte
contre le terrorisme c'est que c'est par
qu'on on va cacher quelque chose
simplement ce qu'on voudrait c'est qu'on
nous laisse temps de faire nos
investigations une enquête avec des
services de police exceptionnels une
police scientifique et technique
remarquable nous a permis de remonter
toute la filière et qui a fait que après
il y a plus
[Musique]
d'attentat la lutte contre le terrorisme
je crois que c'est un point commun à
tous les présidents que nous avons eu le
problème c'est que évidemment c'est
extraordement
difficile parce que d'un côté les foyers
du
terrorisme se dissémine c'est plus
simplement un pays ou une grande
puissance qui finance c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus disparate c'est
un mot tellement général le terrorisme
islamique les attentats dans le métro en
1986 qu'est-ce que c'était
non j'ai connu l'preuve du terrorisme
une fois du terrorisme islamique avec
cette affaire de Toulouse l'exécution de
sangfroid ne fait aucun doute il est
14h10 dans ce petit centre commercial le
tireur sur son scooter attend les trois
militaires qui arrivent en uniforme ils
viennent retirer de l'argent d'autres
personnes sont présentes sur les lieux
le tireur n'agit pas au hasard il vise
les soldats cet individu cet assassin
est le premier des loups
solitaires un homme garçon scooter
devant le collège lycée ZAR àora un
établissement juif de Toulouse il est
7h56 il garde son casque et sort une
première arme un enseignant en religion
de 30 ans et ses deux garçons de 3 et 6
ans qui attendaient devant l'école sont
abattus le meurtrier passe la grille et
tire à l'intérieur de l'établissement en
ce lundi matin beaucoup d'enfants sont
dans la cour il était masqué il avait
une casque il est rentré il a vu son
arme qui était donc il a pris notre arme
pour les abattre comme des chiens à
quatre pattes les deux gosses comme si
c'était des vulgaires des vulgaires
poulet comprenaaient qu'on égorgé
qu'est-ce qu'on peut
calmer faut dire
quoi que le bateau du que le gouvernail
du pays est
tenu que nous savons parfaitement où
nous allons comment nous nous nous y
allons et qu'il faut qu'on ser les
coudes il a pas rassuré il y a rien de
rassurant là-dedans
d'autant plus qu'on sait que ça peut se
reproduire c'est la République toute
entière qui est
mobilisée pour faire face à ce drame
c'est la mort qui
arrive l' l'orreur qui arrive
l'inhumanité la barbarie et il filme
donc excusez-moi mais les élections mon
avenir la présidentielle on n'est pas
dans cette sphère là
j'avais suspendu la campagne en 2012 et
ça a été respecté par tout le monde ils
étaient tous
venus vous savez les périodes d'union
nationale contre l'ennemi de l'extérieur
qui s'est infiltré à l'intérieur c'est
pas les plus difficiles à gérer
politiquement humainement c'est
difficile il y a d'un côté Nicolas
Sarkozy dans toute la solennité de sa
fonction de chef d'État de l'autre les
candidats mais après le recueillement
vient le temps de la
politique moi j'étais alerté conscient
depuis 2012 des risques que courrait
notre pays notamment parce que beaucoup
de de français ou de résidents en France
partaient en Irak et et en Syrie c'est
un mouvement qui n'a cessé de
d'augmenter ce n pas uniquement des
actes terroristes qui vien extérieur
comme cela a été le cas dans les années
70 ou 80 non là c'est c'est un
terrorisme intrinsèque j'avais parlé dès
2012 d'ailleurs d'ennemis extérieur
d'ennemis intérieur ce sont pas des
groupes terroristes seulement de
l'extérieur c'est aussi en are sein
parmi des Français qu'il y a une
idologie qui nourrit la haine de la
France et avec la volonté de de de tuer
des des Français de s'en prendre à ce
que nous sommes Bernard casenu qui
j'avais passé la main en en avril 2014
savait c'est le seul sujet que j'abord
avec lui à ce moment-l au moment la
passation de pouvoir que nous étions
face à un risque majeur en janvier 2015
je suis dans mon bureau et à ce
moment-là je reçois sur mon portable un
appel de Patrick Pelou il me dit je suis
dans la salle de rédaction ils sont tous
morts c'est affreux c'est affreux vient
vient le plus rapidement
possible donc je me rends quelques
minutes plus tard sur les
et je vois ce ce cette scène où des
blessés sortent de la rédaction de
Charlie dans un quartier totalement
bouclé j'apprends que un policier a été
tué par les terroristes nous sommes dans
l'action le le l'obsession c'est la
traque c'est arrêté en l'occurrence les
frères Kachi qui sont dans la nature et
donc les heures les jours qui suivent en
lien avec mes collaborateurs avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur mar
casneuve c'est l'information sur sur la
traque après Charlie c'est c'est ce sont
3 jours hein le
lendemain je suis sur une émission de de
radio et je pense qui s'est passé à
Montrouge une heure plus tôt un banal
accident de voiture a lieu dans cette
rue de Montrouge un peu avant 8h et
soudain une fusillade un homme vêtu de
noir tire sur des policiers municipaux
une policière s'effondre et le vendredi
matin alors que avec fleur pèlerin nous
nous rendons au siège de libération qui
accueille la rédaction de de de Charlie
Hebdo pr il y a une prise d'otage à
l'hypercachè de la porte de de Vincen il
est 17h c'est l'assut qui
déb puis les otages sortent de
l'épicerie dans la plus grande confusion
on distingue des femmes des hommes apuré
qui cherche à se mettre à l'abri mais
dans l'épicerie CQ corps seront
retrouvés quatre otages semble-t-il et
celui du preneur d'otage amedi Koulibali
32 ans qui visiblement n'agissait pas
seul on est soulagé d'une certaine
manière quand tout se termine même si il
y a eu évidemment des morts et et et un
drame qui a qui a marqué durablement
le le pays lorsque il y a eu les
attentats de Charlie et aussi ceux sur
l'hypercachère et aussi sur la policière
de Montrouge il y a eu un
soulèvement un sursaut populaire une
manifestation très importante à Paris
mais aussi des cortèges nombreux dans
toutes les villes de France qui
témoignait que le pays faisait bloc euh
sans que il soit besoin de de de
l'appeler à la
[Musique]
cohésion UMP udips vert les étiquettes
ont disparu Martine au BRI au toit
Valéri pécrè Jean-François Copé rejoint
Jean-Christophe cambadéiss un peu plus
loin Jean-Louis borlot à côté de
marietouren se fond dans le gouvernement
pour tous un discours qui se veut à
l'unisson de celui du peuple français je
ne pense pas voyez-vous que les
oppositions quel qu'elle soit se
déchaîne sur le président lorsqu'il
efface au terrorisme ce n'est pas vrai
en général les gens savent se tenir
toute famille politique confondu dans ce
genre de circonstances et là encore il
faut éviter de se faire des hommes
politiques une image trop dégradé
euh l'intérêt national prévaut et puis
il y avait même une forme de solidarité
internationale qui s'était formé j'avais
moi-même pris la tête d'une d'un défilé
où était rassembler des chefs d'État qui
ne se parlaient plus peut-être depuis
des années on a ce sentiment là quand
même que sur ce sujet il y a rien qui
peut nous diviser je pense que c'est une
des forces quand même de la France
malgré tout que en ce qui concerne le
terrorisme la réponse c'est l'unité
nationale c'est un moment d'émotion mais
si a une très grande volonté de de Ten
tenir ferme face au terrorisme parce une
prise de conscience que nous en avons
pour un certain temps et que nous
faisons face à une véritable guerre donc
il faut tenir bon sur la République la
laïcité bon donc il y a tout un travail
à faire donc faut pas lâcher et le
risque c'est toujours que bah parce que
il y a les cantonnales parce qu'il y a
une loi Macron sur les réformes
économiques qui nous obligeront aussi un
493 il y a d'autres sujets d'actualité
qui s'imposent et puis on on a pas envie
de parler que des sujets grave et donc
on oublie et quand arrive un autre
attentat à ce moment-là les gens sont
surpris mais pas moi
le le vendredi
13 novembre le matin même mon équipe à
Matignon lit et relie une note du
secrétariat général à la Défense
nationale sur le mode opératoire de
l'État suite à un attentat multicite et
notamment sur le fait qu'il faut mettre
en œuvre l'état l'état d'urgence la la
sécurité civile et les Sapeurs Pompiers
de Paris ont organisé une opération en
cas d'attentat multide donc c'est
quelque chose qui qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
existe c'est un match de gala le
président Hollande a fait le déplacement
pour venir voir ce France- Allemagne je
suis dans le stade le match vient de
commencer et j'entends très
distinctement une première
explosion je ne sais pas ce qu'elle
traduit est-ce que c'est un pétard
est-ce que c'est une bombe agricole je
ne vois aucune panique dans le public
qui pourrait laisser penser que la bombe
a éclaté à l'intérieur du stade et donc
j'attends et quelques minutes plus tard
il y a une deuxième
explosion et à ce moment-là je suis
informé
dans un temps très court qu'il y a un
mort à l'extérieur du stade et qu'il n'y
a pas de doute sur le caractère
terroriste de de cette attaque et je
reçois un appel du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui me dit je vais à au
Stade de France parce qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose il y a une explosion je
dois prendre deux décisions la première
c'est de savoir ce que l'on fait avec le
match lui-même si on il est interrompu
il est à craintre que pour évacuer le
public qui sort à ce moment-là qu'il y a
eu une explosion il peut y avoir une
panique des gens écrasés ce que je pense
être l'intention des terroristes qui ont
fait exploser la
[Applaudissements]
bombe au début je dois être présent dans
les tribunes et prévenir tous ceux qui
sont autour de moi y compris notre
invité
allemand de façon à ce que tous les
officiels restent sur
place sans que le public puisse
entrevoir un mouvement de retrait je
reçois un appel d'un journaliste qui qui
me dit mais je sens une voix paniquée il
habite juste en face de la du bar la
belle équipe il me dit on est en train
de tirer il y a des gens par terre c'est
terrible c'est affreux et je suis
prévenu par Manuel Vals Premier ministre
qu'il y a une attaque terroriste
semble-t-il de grande envergure au cœur
de Paris puis je m'éclipse et je vais
dans le lieu où sont rassemblés tous les
services de et à ce moment-là je
comprends immédiatement qu'on fait face
à cet attentat multicite et je dis ça y
est je crois que l'expression qui est là
la mienne ça y est on y est on est face
à quelque chose de terrible parce que
Stade de France même si on a pas tous
les éléments belle équipe il y a pas
encore le Bataclan mais ça veut dire que
nous sommes en train d'être attaqués et
on mesure pas encore l'ampleur sur
plusieurs sites sur plusieurs
[Musique]
endroits quelques minutes après reprise
de la partie je je pars vers le
ministère de l'intérieur avec Bernard
knuf qui m'a rejoint et dès mon arrivée
place beauovau au ministère de
l'Intérieur je déclare l'état d'urgence
c'est-à-dire que je convoque un conseil
des ministres pour que nous puissions
prendre des dispositions liées à l'état
d'urgence nous sommes déjà à ce
moment-là à beauau et nous apprenons
que des terroristes sont dans le
Bataclan qu'est-ce que je ressens
d'abord que l'attaque n'est pas terminée
que nous sommes devant une opération de
guerre que si nous n'arrêtons pas les
terroristes il peut y avoir une
répétition dans les jours qui vont
suivre nous comprenons très vite qu'il y
aura parce que nous avons déjà les
premiers bilans sur sur les terrasses de
nombreux morts beaucoup de
mort que
ressent une société quand elle est
frappée en son cœur dans sa capitale sur
les terrasses de café dans un stade dans
un lieu de spectacle quelle va être la
réaction est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un
danger majeur de de fracturation
d'éclatement et peut-être de violence
d'où la question quand le président
doit-il s'exprimer au moment oùùù les
attaques se font ou une fois qu'on a un
certain nombre d'informations à
communiquer au pays et une appré ce qui
s'est passé dans cette nuit et je décide
de parler ce qui est assez inhabituel à
minuit à la télévision mes chers
compatriotes au moment où je
m'exprime des attaques terroristes d'une
ampleur sans précédent sont en cours
dans l'agglomération
parisienne il y a plusieurs dizaines de
tués il y a beaucoup de
blessés c'est une horreur
nous
avons sur ma décision mobilisé toutes
les forces possibles et j'ai vu François
Hollande particulièrement marqué ça
s'est vu d'ailleurs à la télévision ce
ce soir-là pour des raisons profondément
humaine ça restera sans doute
l'intervention la plus
importante de de mon mandat il y a
effectivement de quoi avoir peur il y a
l'effroid mais il y a face à l'effroid
une nation qui sait se défendre qui sait
mobiliser ses forces et qui une fois
encore sera vaincre les
terroristes l'assaut est terminé il a
duré 10 minutes les otages sont
évacués je considère que c'est au
président de la République prenant des
précautions d'aller sur place et d'aller
au Bataclan je pense une très mauvaise
décision et c'est ainsi pouvait pas
empêcher François Hollande tout le monde
sait que qu'il aurait pu avoir une autre
réplique mais dans ce qu'est la réalité
de la France Politique un président
américain n' jamais pu le faire et j'ai
donc été informé qu'effectivement me
rendant sur place même s'il était très
tard près d'une heure du matin il
pouvait y avoir une menace par la
présence d'un groupe de terroristes
François Hollande et moi-même Bernard
casen ça n'a rien àir avec le courage
nous considérons que notre rôle c'est
d'être là-bas
je n'oublierai jamais les images de
personnes qui sortaient encore du
Bataclan de ceux qui avaient assister à
cette
tragédie à cette horreur et qui me
voyait qui à ce momentlà prenait
conscience que nous étions auprès d'eux
et que nous étions dans dans une
situation exceptionnelle c'est avec le
Bataclan que la vague
de la monstruosité nous
atteint C avec le Bataclan que ce que
nous croyons impossible
arrive c'est avec le Bataclan et toute
cette mobilisation que finalement on est
tous directement
atte le Bataclan c'est nous c'est le
pays c'est tout le monde
nous sommes des politique mais au bon
sens du du terme c'estàd que nous sommes
conscients que la réaction de
l'opinion la réaction des Français et
c'est normal ne sera plus du tout la
même celle de janvier donc il fallait
trouver une réponse institutionnelle qui
pouvait plus être la réponse par la
grande
[Musique]
manifestation
le président de la républ d'ù le
discours au Congrès à Versailles d'ù
l'annonce d'un certain nombre de
dispositions le terrorisme ne détruira
pas la République car c'est la
République qui le détruira et pour
gagner cette guerre près de 8000 postes
sont créés dans la police la justice la
défense Françis Hollande demande aussi
la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence président Hollande s'est
exprimé devant le le Congrès je trouve
qu'il a chaque fois trouvé les mots
justes j'ai les souvenir debout tous ces
parlementaires qui qui saluaient pas
simplement le discours mais ce qu' le
contenait il a été très applaudi bien
sûr bien sûr parce que tout ce qu'il a
dit était puissant était juste était
fort à l'exception je dirais de cette
idée de déchéance de nationalité nous
devons pouvoir expulser plus plus
rapidement les étrangers qui
représentent une menace d'une
particulière gravité pour l'ordre public
et la sécurité de la nation là je dois
dire que je n'ai pas compris d'où ça
sortait et j'ai pas été le seul la
déchéance de nationalité qui je rappelle
existe dans notre droit et et qui était
élargi uniquement pour les crimes de
terroristes cette disposition qui
finalement avait été saluée par le
Congrès tout entier et bien il y a eu un
débat qui s'est introduit et et souvent
de bonne foi ceux qui pensaient qu'on
remettait en cause le droit de la
nationalité et donc quand j'ai vu queil
y avait cette somme
d'incompréhension de surencher de de
raccourci je sais pas ce qu'il faut dire
en tout cas de malentendu entretenu
délibérément ou même la droite qui avait
demandé cette disposition ne voulait
même plus la voter en tout cas une
partie d'entre elles bon on m'a dit
écoutez puisque on voulait pas me donner
si je puis dire satisfaction pour avoir
mené cette dispos position qui est en
plus introduisé dans notre droit
constitutionnel l'état d'urgence j'ai
préféré retirer ça pour assurer le
consensus je n'ai qu'un seul regret je
veux ici l'exprimer c'est d'avoir
proposé la déchéance de nationalité
parce que je pensais qu'elle pouvait
nous unir alors qu'elle nous a divisé
Christian tobira qui lorsque la
l'annonce avait été faite nen avait pas
été heurté mais qui ensuite à mesure que
le débat se poursuivait comprenait pas
pourquoi on passait par une révision
constitutionnelle m'avait signalé
qu'elle souhaitait quitter le
gouvernement je luii demandé de retenir
sa décision pendant plusieurs semaines
ce qu'elle a fait et ensuite elle est
partie il y a effectivement à gauche une
tradition qui fait
que toute attitude répressive est
considérée comme
attentatoire au principe des libertés
l'homme n'est ni ange ni bête mais qui
veut faire l'ange et la bête et il me
semble que à gauche on ferait bien de
s'inspirer de ce proverbe pascalien il y
a deux principes si je peux dire qui
sont apparemment en
opposition d'un
côté vous devez assurer la sécurité de
la population la sécurité c'est un droit
un droit absolu de l'autre il y a des
libertés euh qui sont des libertés
essentielles auxquelles il ne faut pas
porter atteinte comme euh président de
la République Premier ministre ou
ministre concerné euh vous avez à faire
cet arbitrage donc tout est dans un
dosage il faut être
ferme mais il ne faut pas être injuste
c'est un truisme la sécurité c'est le
premier des droits de l'homme parce que
la sécurité c'est toujours les plus
faibles qui sont les premiers atteints
l'armée va donc se déployer en force sur
tout le territoire 5000 hommes étaient
mobilisés jusque là désormais ce sera le
double c'est bien le signe que la menace
terroriste est toujours là l'état
d'urgence est un bon exemple de ce que
doit être cet équilibre quand je décide
de l'utiliser l'état d'urgence c'est
pour permettre qu'il y ait des
perquisitions et aussi des assignations
à résidence d'individus dont on peut
penser qu'ils sont plus ou moins liés à
des groupes qui pourraient être
dangereux mais si l'état d'urgence se
poursuit au-delà de ce qui est
nécessaire à ce momentl nous rentrons
dans une autre manière de vivre en
République ou c'est l'état du soupçon
quand on me parlait de mettre dans des
camps les fichers s ça c'est
guantonamo ça n'existe pas dans notre
droit français heureusement donc
trouverz toujours la limite pour nous
protéger sans pour autant nous mettre
hors de nos règles
républicaines et c'est c'est ce que doit
faire un président à chaque instant en
sachant bien qu'à un moment il faut
remettre en cause des libertés y compris
des libertés de manifester c'est grave
de remettre en cause liberté de
manifester mais c'était dans
l'intérêt de tous c'était pour éviter
que des groupes terroristes puissent
s'introduire dans des manifestations et
fassent exposer éventuellement une bombe
il y a des sujets sur lesquels je ne dis
pas qu'il faut se transformer en tyran
hein c'est pas du tout ce que je veux
dire mais enfin il y a des circ B sens
ou ce qui prime ce sont les intérêts de
la lutte contre ce qui violle les les
principes fondamentaux d'un état de
droit moi je n'ai jamais vu d'atteinte
aux libertés dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui me paraisse à moi à un
moment donné excessive nous avons pu
faire voter des lois importantes à une
très large majorité droite gauche à
l'Assemblée au Sénat le groupe l'UMP ou
les républicains en nous nous nous nous
se
tenait le 14 juillet 2016 c'est un
basculement Nice c'est un individu
fanatisé qui prend un camion et qui
hélas roule sur des femmes des enfants
des hommes et commet des actes
irréparable mais il y'y a pas une
organisation derrière lui n sommes pas
devant une attaque d'envergure qui
vient menacer notre pays ensuite il y a
une polémique qui qui
nourrit
localement sur les conditions de de
sécurité par rapport à l'organisation de
ce 14 juillet de ce feu d'artifice
comment est-il possible qu'un jour de 14
juillet alors qu'il y a des milliers de
personnes sur la Promenade des Anglais
un camion puisse pénétrer dans ces
conditions sur le plan politique il y a
là des facilités qui sont déplorables
parce que c'est toujours mettre en cause
des services de sécurité de laisser
penser que il n'y aurait pas eu à chaque
fois le bon réflexe alors que des des
hommes ont donné parfois leur vie pour
que nous puissions être en sécurité
comme après les attentats de 2015
Franois Hollande appelle à l'unité
nationale dès son arrivée à Nice le chef
de l'État n'entend pas laisser prospérer
les critiques contre l'exécutif c'est ma
responsabilité
ne pas me laisser
détourner de l'engagement que j'ai pris
au nom des Français de les protéger ne
pas m'abaisser à je ne sais quel
outrance
excès l'essentiel c'est la force qu'on
représente et donc c'est cette force
qu'il faut mettre en avant et donc c'est
forcément l'unité nationale la la force
qu'on peut représenter c'est pas en
attaquant l'adversaire qu'on se renforce
ça c'est la logique du populisme ben
vous savez l'Union nationale c'est une
résultante c'est pas un
objectif c'est une nécessité du moment
pour régler certains problèmes mais ici
on prend comme objectif qu'il faut à
tout prix maintenir l'unité nationale en
toutes circonstances on ne fait plus
rien c'est pour profondément triste car
face à à ce genre d'événement ce qui est
important c'est la cohésion nationale il
faut respecter des temps de silence et
des temps d'union et ne pas toujours
tomber dans la polémique politique les
terroristes savent
que cherche en en en en à travers C ces
attentats à créé une confrontation nous
sommes fragiles parce que parce que nous
avons une opinion qui qui qui réagit
mais parce que nous sommes attaqués
parce que nous sommes des démocraties ou
parce qu'on nous attaqu au nom de notre
idée de la République et de la laïcité
il faut d'autant plus
tenir
ce soir la mort d'un professeur
d'histoire dans les iveline il a été
attaqué au couteau à proximité d'un
établissement scolaire il aurait montré
à ses élèves des caricatures de mom
agress nous continuerons professeur nous
défendrons la liberté que vous enseigz
si bien et nous porterons ha la
laïcité parce qu'en
France les lumières ne s'éteignent
jamais vive la
République vive la
France les démocraties ont toujours
vaincu le terrorisme quel que fut sa
nature et et par les moyens du droit
finalement quelle était la meilleure
réponse par rapport aux attaques dont
nous avons été l'objet c'est bien sûr de
faire la guerre on nous faisait la
guerre il fallait y répondre mais
c'était aussi d'avoir un procès où même
des accusés pouvaient avoir des avocats
pour se défendre et que la justice
républicaine pouvait à ce momentl les
condamner avec le respect du droit mais
la force du droit c'est donc un procès
d'une ampleur tout à fait inédite qui
s'est ouvert il y a quelques instants
devant la Cour d'assis spécial de Paris
cela va durer 9 mois 20 personnes il
seront jugées parmi lesquelles le
terroriste présumé salab Abdel
slam supposer un
instant
queon rétablisse la peine de mort en
matière de
terrorisme le résultat sera bien pire
qu'est-ce qu'un terroriste
exécuté celui qui est allé au
bout de sa sa conviction et qui a agi et
pas seulement parl donc c'est un héros
et le lendemain vous aurez la
constitution de commandau de jeunes gens
qui porteront le nom de celui qu'on aura
exécuté et loin d'arrêter le terrorisme
vous
multiplierez les terroristes parce que
vous aurez rendu héroïque celui qui
sinon pour une longue longue longue nuit
pénitentiaire
disparaî c'est un grand soulagement pour
les parties civiles du procès du 13
novembre la cour d'assise spéciale de
Paris a condamné ce mercredi
salabdeslam à la perpétuité
incompressible cette peine jusque là
elle n'avait été prononcée qu'à qu
reprises en
France on ne peut pas ça serait un trop
grand service rendre à ces fous à ces
assassins que de mettre par terre nos
règles pour s'adapter à eux quand on
regarde un petit peu la situation
aujourd'hui sur la planète on se rend
compte que on assiste à un progrès
partout des populismes des extrémismes
des fanatismes un recul de la
démocratie
l'Occident n'est plus le centre du monde
nos valeurs démocratique ne sont plus la
référence universelle mais c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont pas acceptées
partout qu'il faut que nous nous
excusions au
[Musique]
contraire